and you tonight after eight years a
nevada woman says her voice has finally
been heard helen armstrong says she lost
her job after reporting what she calls
unsafe practices at a local medical
office but this week the ninth circuit
appeals court ruled in her favor and
turned everything around sasha loftis
joins us live with her story
denise helen says this entire process
has just been excruciating but the
decision made this week she calls it a
huge step forward for her and anyone
else in a similar situation
it ruined my life helen armstrong shares
the hardest thing she's ever had to go
through i've lost a lot in 2014 she was
working at a local medical practice and
reported to nevada osha what she calls
unsafe practices
including the distribution of expired
drugs and use of contaminated syringes
armstrong says she was told she would
stay anonymous but claims state
officials notified her former bosses of
her claims against them which led to
retaliation and her eventual firing
being fired not having insurance
diagnosed with cancer
wasn't good she tried to get her life
back but hit numerous legal roadblocks
until the u.s court of appeals for the
9th circuit handed her a victory this
week allowing her 2017 lawsuit against
nevada officials to move forward this is
an important precedent attorney john
thai says the unanimous ruling in
helen's favor will also benefit others
in similar situations
every whistleblower
you know has a right to be protected
though she believes this battle is far
from over helen is grateful to finally
feel hurt and she encourages others to
always fight for what they feel is right
know that you have rights out there you
have rights
we did reach out to nevada osha
regarding this case a representative
responded saying they have no comment
now as for that ninth circuit appeal we
have an entire look at that on our
website 8newsnow.com
reporting live in the newsroom tonight
sasha loftis live local now